Romeo heard his friends calling for him, but he did not respond.
It was cold and dark under the trees in the Capulet's garden.
He only cared about his new love, Juliet.
He sat and shivered and looked at the house,...
...dreaming about Juliet's beauty, and remembering her kiss.
He saw a light in one of the rooms, and then he saw a girl come out onto the balcony.
It was Juliet and he could see her!
"Oh, Romeo, Romeo! Why do you have to be Romeo?"
"Why are you a Montague? Forget about your father and change your name."
"If you cannot, I will forget about my father and change my name."
"I will no longer be a Capulet."
This was too much for Romeo. He could no longer stay quiet.
"If you say you love me, I will change my name."
"From now on, I will never be Romeo!"
"Love made it easy to climb the wall because walls cannot stop love."
"Nor is love afraid of danger. If your family hates me, let them kill me."
"It is better to die by their hate than to live without your love."
"I love you!"
Juliet was glad that it was dark because she blushed and did not want Romeo to see it.